I promise that if you go home after this
conference and audit yourself and think
about your 10 12h hour day and really
look at it 25% of the time you're
spending you're spending on dumb
you're spending it on something that you
can replace with an $8 to12 an hour
employee or you're spending it on
something you've historically done and
you're just used to doing it or you're
doing something that actually just
brings no to little value to your actual
business if you take that
25% of your time and you apply that to
engage
and conversating with the end consumer
of your business you will see results
the person that is closest to the end
consumer wins